at the height of the BLM riots back in
August of 2020 Kyle Rittenhouse went to
Kenosha Wisconsin when his father lived
and that night because he was asked to
he helped protect local businesses From
the Mob of people looting destroying and
burning as he was doing that a mentally
ill child molester called Joseph
Rosenbaum tried to kill ritten the house
Rittenhouse defended himself and shot
Rosenbaum and then several of him began
chasing Rittenhouse down the street one
of them was called Gage Grace Cruz
Ritter house went to the ground Grace
Cruz pointed a gun at him in response
Rittenhouse shot him in the arm that was
obviously self-defense it was on camera
and gross crates admitted that at trial
watch
does this look like right now your arm
is being shot that looks like my bicep
being vaporized yes okay
and it's being vaporized as you're
pointing your gun directly at him yes
yes okay so
when you were standing three to five
feet from him with your arms up in the
air he never fired right
correct it wasn't until you pointed your
gun at him
he fanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
be fired right
correct
so yes I pointed a loaded gun in his
face because I wanted to kill him and he
shot me in the arm disabling me and
prevented me from killing him
well yeah that's the appropriate use of
force in the cause of self-defense but
because self-defense is no longer loud
in the United States the man who tried
to kill Kyle Rittenhouse is now suing
Kyle Rittenhouse for preventing him from
killing Kyle Rittenhouse Kyle
Rittenhouse joins us now Kyle thanks so
much for coming on it's almost
unbelievable that a man who tried to
kill you and was prevented from killing
you by your act of self-defense is now
suing you because he wasn't able to kill
you how does that work
thank you for having me Tucker and
honestly I have no idea it's it's
ridiculous it's a lawsuit it's very
frustrating and It's upsetting this is
honestly to me an attack on our Second
Amendment rights and our rights to
self-defense
and it's saying if you use your
god-given right to self-defense they're
going to come after you if you win a
court you're acquitted rightfully so
they're going to take you to civil court
and they're going to file they're going
to take you for everything you're worth
they're going to drive you into
bankruptcy and drown you in a mountain
of legal bills
that's what's actually happening we're
watching this happen all over the
country uh civil suits used to shut down
free speech to end the Second Amendment
to avoid the Bill of Rights and to
destroy people who stand up against the
mob like you who's funding this suit do
you have any idea
I have no idea who's funding this
lawsuit all I know is that there's a
Powerhouse of attorneys behind Gage
growth scruts and I have Mark Richards
and I know we're going to win to court
but it's going to be expensive it's
going to cost a lot of money to fight
these attorneys are very powerful you
can go to
www.givesango.com
rented house to help me take on these
lawyers so they don't come after more
people because if they can come after me
they will come after you
well of course and they are coming after
people all over the country it's an
undercovered Story the use of the Civil
courts to void the Bill of Rights and
Destroy anyone who stands in the way of
their Total Takeover of the country how
old are you by the way at this point
I'm 20 years old I was 17 when Gage
graduates pointed the pistol in my head
yeah a loaded a loaded pistol and tried
to kill you and you did absolutely the
right thing and you disabled him before
he could murder you
um and I assume at 20 you probably just
kind of want to go live the rest of your
one hopes long life right
absolutely but you know they're trying
to they they don't want me to like they
want me to go away but they want to
drown me in these legal debt these legal
bills and they want to sue me and pretty
much not allow me to live in normal 20
year old life
yeah well you did the right thing you
know if someone points a loaded gun in
your face and tries to kill you you have
not just to write but an obligation to
respond and you did uh so Kyle
Rittenhouse thank you so much for
joining us tonight and Godspeed thank
you
and what's happening to you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight